advert i was a live starting pitcher for
the cubs tonight leans heavily on that
slide ball 45 percent of the time sinker
four seamer change up and curveball
unlined left field peterson coming on
brad miller making his first start
that's bounced to first it's rizzo
and he gets it to owls a lot bryce
harper ready to step in harper lines a
one-humper glove by rizzo nice play
anthony runs over stomps on the bag
nicely done three up three down
right-hander zach keflan the 27 year old
is three and six
with an era of 4.13 and his last outing
he struck out two won six innings the
phillies won the game four to two one
two pitch and a swing and a missy struck
him out peterson couldn't spoil that one
so a strikeout for eflin to start here's
patrick wisdom who's two for five in
this series swinging a smash into left
field base hit
gregorius tried to make a backhand stop
on a short hop the ball an absolute
bullet that just ate him up here's
anthony rizzo
swag and a miss
it's two strikeouts on two breaking
pitches at two outs for jason hayward
backliner base hit into right field
wisdom's not stopping on his way to
third harper will pick it up and jason
hayward shatters the bat and they're at
the corners two outs for robinson
chorinos pitch number nine in this
at-bat two runners on
swing at a miss
he finally threw him a slider it was not
on the spot the jt wanted it but he got
the strikeout he strikes out three the
first base runner for the phillies is jt
ramuto with a walk and that brings deedy
up
ground ball past rizzo down the right
field line it hits the wall real muto
goes to third hayward's throw to second
and the phillies have something to cook
it it's first and third with nobody out
anthony rizzo you know that's a play he
makes 99 out of 100 times apparently
that was the 100th one here's odubal
herrera
good pitch and he struck him out on a
slider in the dirt outstanding right
here getting on top of that slider a
terrific job on the part of torino
here's alec baume the 3-2 from alzali
he does swing it a miss rudder goes
throw is off the mark coming home is
real muto and he runs into chirinos
and then hits the plate he scores it's
one nothing phillies
nine times out of ten jt real muto is
going to win that battle whether he's
catching or running it's a double steal
and the fills take the early lead corner
will hold with a single as the cubs get
a man on
contra rips it out to right harper going
back makes the catch over shoulder
horner
was about three quarters of the way to
second about halfway back on the warning
track over the shoulder grab by harper
nicely done there's out number two two
on two outs top of the order coming up
and here is jack peterson three two
ground ball right side
segura's got it zips the throw over in
time four three on the put out a couple
base runners again but the cubs leave a
couple down it'll bring up gene segura
swag and a miss al zalade the strikeout
and that's his third
2-0 to miller we ground it out to first
his first time up
out to left field
that's pretty well hit through the wind
it's gone
brad miller the opposite way a solo home
run the phillies lead it two nothing joe
rolled the dice to put another
left-hander in the lineup and here in
the third it pays off
seven home runs 21 runs batted in for
miller and one out here in the third
batter is anthony rizzo
went upstairs with a fastball at 94.
that's the fourth strikeout for zach
kepler next pitch swinging a miss he
didn't make contact with this one jt
will pick it out of the dirt fired down
first and there's a one two three inning
for zach f here's jt he walked and
scored his first time up against owls
ally
got him swinging so real mute joe
retired check out number four for alex
alive most of the swings and misses
tonight have come on that slider nothing
new there dd gregorius
drop baby drop left center field it's
going to drop it it's going to one hop
the iv
and gregorius is going to get to second
base with his second hit that's six
doubles for dede down to third goes
deedy but now two outs in the inning and
it'll be up to alec balm the 3-2 pitch
swinging a miss he struck him out
he needed that strikeout and gregorius
left stranded the rudder at second
two outs and the phillies need a clutch
two out base hit for brad miller swung
on and belted high and deep right field
and forget about it it is gone brad
miller with a two homer night this time
it's a two run home run and he has put
the phillies up four to nothing it's his
eighth home run of the season as miller
tees off on an 02 pitch
i mean he
absolutely crushed it and they're on the
corners for travis jankowski phillies
are one for eight with runners in
scoring position tonight
ball four it'll load the bases up and
eflin is walking to the plate the strike
two pitch on the way from abbott bouncer
to third glove by wisdom he'll toss
across and that ends the inning eugene
segura aboard with a leadoff single
four-nothing phillies brad miller of the
batter
oh my gosh crushes it to right field
it's a three-home run game
off the lineup on the scoreboard
they better get a third homer hat brad
miller is living his best life
another two-run home run
and the phillies lead it six-nothing
first phillies player to hit three home
runs of the game since jason wirth back
in may of 2008. wow what a night for
brad miller
down the left field line harper
he's hustling his way to second and he
is there standing look at that exit
velocity 63 baby and here's d.d
gregorius coming up
dede hits that one to deep right center
field and that one is gone just over the
basket and then in another two run home
run they had to borrow a homer hat for
brad miller
and dede with his ninth home run
we'll have to talk to andrew knapp about
that eight nothing
it's out number one here's nico horner
ground ball over toward first diving
stop by brad miller throws to second
gets the lead runner i mean you know
look this is a good play ranged a long
way i don't know maybe put him in the
pitch the last couple innings too yeah
why not
popped up
outside of third bowm
is there whoa what a play
and alec baum secures the final out here
in the bottom of the seventh as he
reaches in over the cubs dugout to make
that play brad miller will get another
chance brad miller with three home runs
adam morgan is on the mound
just missed it
right side of the infield horner
makes the grab well
three is pretty special yeah look at
that steve yeah we'll give him a hint
i'm sure that was impressive they've
seen a lot of baseball games watch
reese's dad too
on the swing
[Music]
two men down one ball and two strikes
and a call strike three 95 perfectly
placed on the outside part of the plate
and the phillies do indeed take three of
four from the cubs
helped by the long ball of brad miller
tonight what a moment what a moment to
share that with your mom and dad